what are the health risks that guys
should consider if they're thinking
about going on trt well it depends the
context in which they enter into that
because again if you don't actually need
it and you get on it you could be making
yourself less healthy but if you do need
it and you're clinically deficient and
again not medical advice but in general
you're going to be more prone to things
like cardiovascular disease
neurodegeneration Etc so it's kind of
like if you actually clinically need
something to then say what is the
downside to trt it's like what is the
downside of not being on trt at that
point potentially that's kind of how I
would frame it for the actual clinical
utility of it in a real deficient
setting it's kind of like what could you
be staving off by using it in a
responsible way